في وقت اخر فيه السلطات الصينيه اجراءات
مكافحه كورونا الاحترازيه تقف البلاد امام
مفترق طرق يحمل فيها الاصابات الى ذروتها
ذروه تتوقع السلطات ان تفقد معها مزيدا من
الضغط على النظام الصحي الذي يعاني
بالاحساس بسبب التغيير المفاجئ في السياسه
الصينيه الى مباغته النظام الصحي الهش
الذي لم يكن مستعدا لذلك في وقت تتدافع
فيه المستشفيات لتامين اسره واكياس دم
للمصابين بينما تتسابق الصيدليات لتوفير
الادويه لكن مدير المركز الوطني للامراض
المعديه في شنغهاي اشار الى ان الموجه
الجديده من الاصابات ستستمر لشهر او شهرين
وسيكون لها تاثير مؤكد على الموارد الطبيه
باكملها
وتبدو شنغهاي العصب الاقتصادي
لثاني اقتصاد في العالم مرشحه لتكون بؤره
اصابات بكرونا فحسب تقديرات طبيه فان نصف
سكان المدينه الذي يبلغ عددهم 25 مليون
نسمه قد يصابون بالمرض بحلول نهايه
الاسبوع المقبل وما تفسي فيروس كورونا بدا
السكان الذين خضعوا في السابق للعزل
لفترات طويله في تعلم سبل التعايش مع
الفيروس الذي رغم تطوير الصين لوحدها تسعه
لقاحات ما زال بعيدا عن الانسان